ciao a tutti
ciao
come siete belli bellissimi voi
conoscete un metodo formativo
alternativo
beh io sì io conosco l'improvvisazione
teatrale il metodo formativo che io
utilizzo
oggi vivo 8 accompagnare in un viaggio
un viaggio lunghissimo per farvi capire
che cos'è l'improvvisazione
ok partendo dal tema cadere e rialzarsi
un tema che ci accompagna per tutta la
nostra vita fin da quando da bambini
cerchiamo di camminare a quando magari
proviamo a dare in bicicletta senza le
rotelline o proviamo ancora a invitare
la più carina della classe a quando
magari facciamo atletica
chi è che non ha mai fatto atletica le
scuole cioè che non si è mai sentito
almeno per un breve periodo della sua
vita un atleta grande atleta
io sì io mi sono sentito un atleta un
grande telethon grande salto a creare di
lungo alle medie ero abbastanza alto era
abbastanza muscolose risolverò il più
vario della scuola finché non arrivò lui
davide monti 11 anni e 173 cm di altezza
una cosa non normale questa comunque sta
di fatto che dargli dei monti al suo
primo salto polverizzando i record
superando d'un metro e 2 cm in quel
campo di atletica in una mattina di metà
maggio
io ebbi la mia prima caduta ma mi
rialzai enia lean così tanto ma così
tanto ma così tanto che l'anno
successivo ai giochi
riuscire ad aprire un salto in lungo
davide monti era assente perché era
malato ma questo non c'entra il discorso
è un altro discorso che ci è capitato
tantissime volte nella nostra vita di
cadere e rialzarsi ma noi piano piano ce
ne dimentichiamo
piano piano mentre cresciamo questo
istinto di non mollare un istinto che
tutti hanno fin da bambine anche la mia
piccola bimba livia è un istinto
incredibile di non mollare finché non e
non ottiene quello che vuole ma noi
crescendo piano piano piano piano però
che hanno questo istinto diminuisce e
secondo voi perchè perchè c'è la paura
di giudizio che ci impedisce di fare
quello che vorremmo fare allora come
fare per superarlo per prendere una
decisione senza pensare alle conseguenze
o parlo solo di cose legali e
naturalmente io ho trovate un
improvvisazione teatrale tutti voi
conoscete l'improvvisazione la possiamo
trovare non so
nella canzone nella musica nel freestyle
nel rap
ok nel jazz nel teatro l'improvvisazione
è ovunque e nell'amore e nel lavoro e
nella vita e che ora in questo momento
vi faccio un esempio se lui
stai bene tutto ok no le analisi fatte
sono in questo momento avesse un infarto
io sarei costretto improvvisare lo stato
sarebbe costretto a improvvisare tutti
noi dovremmo
tranne lui che probabilmente visto il
traffico di milano sarebbe morto dunque
l'improvvisazione e ovunque quello
vogliate o no ma sappiamo realmente cosa
vuol dire improvvisare molti danno
un'accezione negativa questa cosa si
pensa che sia a trovare una soluzione
rapida raffazzonata sbilenca
e invece no o almeno non lo è per chi
come me lo fa di mestiere improvvisare
significa trovare una soluzione rapida
ed efficace
attingendo alle proprie competenze
è una grande esperienza creativa e
formativa c'è dentro tutto questo è vero
chirurgo charles limbe buio in due
giorni da di zarra cioè infilare il
jazzista dentro una macchina per la
risonanza magnetica assieme non infine
una tastiera e gli dice ok suona prima
sono un brano memorizzato poi un brano
improvvisato e durante l'improvvisazione
monitorando il cervello
ok si nota che l'area dedicata all'auto
controllo diminuisce e invece aumenta
quella dell'autobiografia dopodichè
chartering fa un'altra cosa
straordinaria infila un secondo jazzista
all'interno della macchina della
risonanza magnetica
poi improvvisa risse me qui si accende
l'area di broca deputata al linguaggio
la comunicazione
dopodichè infila dentro anche un rapper
spero non insieme ai due musicisti e
tastiera sicuramente gli arrestati
lui lo monitorizza e vedendo mentre
improvvisa le aree verbali e visive si
sviluppano dunque partiamo da qui
l'improvvisazione aumenta la nostra
capacità creativa
l'aumento di capacità creativa ci
migliora ci fa crescere non ci fa essere
un cliché di noi stessi ecco attraverso
l'improvvisazione teatrale noi ci
confrontiamo sempre cosa sconosciuto
cambiamo scena rapidamente lavoreremo
con i bebè nostre dunque questo ci fa
crescere e c'era forti radici
rappresenta sempre fare questo tipo di
percorso si migliora e poi ci fa
confrontare continuamente con l'errore e
vedere l'errore sotto un punto di vista
positivo strano eh
e se lo errore forse l'inizio e non la
fine questa è la riconoscerete la
scarpetta di cristallo chance per
scrittori di fine seicento francese fece
la sua versione di cenerentola
ok in un libro che divenne molto famoso
dal titolo i racconti di mamma oca che
io e l'ultimo libro che ho letto lui
nella sua versione la scarpetta di
cenerentola avrebbe dovuto essere vers
vale92 divenne ger v
rr
vetro ma volete mettere quanto e più
romantico a una scarpetta in vetro
anziché di pelliccia a nessuno mai
venuto in mente di cambiarla cenerentole
stata consacrata come l'asi come la
principessa con la sua scarpetta di
cristallo
adesso io mi farebbe far vedere la scena
se la scarpetta non fosse in cristallo
immaginate da don mezzanotti il principe
cenerentole wanda tema si sa la
scarpetta meno male calciando scarpetta
a in pelliccia che bella scarpetta che
bella idea
il 15 d'agosto una scarpetta in
pelliccia semmai la richiamo vedete
cenerentola sarebbe rimasta zitella se
incontri nell'ormai meno sconosciuto
vai ne mori dice facendo le cose che hai
sempre fatto ripeterai sempre le stesse
cose anche in quello che voi fate la
creatività è molto importante
quelli che ce l'hanno fatta hanno avuto
un guizzo creativo in più sono andati
oltre
però la creatività non ha sempre il
giusto peso nella nostra vita nel nostro
lavoro
questa è la dottoressa teresa amabile
direttrice della facoltà di business
abile striscia ad harvard lei dice in
una sua intervista in harvard business
revi
che la creatività non ho mai il giusto
peso all'interno di un'azienda e molte
aziende senza vedere la soffocano tutti
sono convinti che la creatività sia solo
una caratteristica artistica ma non è
così può essere declinata
tranquillamente all'interno di ogni
azienda e presuppone tre componenti la
competenza il talento e la motivazione
il talento è l'immaginazione della
flessibilità con la quale si risolvono i
problemi
la motivazione può essere personale è
dettata dall ambiente di lavoro dentro
disastri e ti insegna questo a imparare
qualche cosa di più di te stesso che
magari pensati di non avere in questo
viaggio
un'altra cosa che ti dice
l'improvvisazione è ascolta tutti noi
conosciamo la frase del famoso filosofo
greco zenone che diceva il motivo per
cui abbiamo d'ore che è una sola bocca e
perché dobbiamo ascoltare il doppio e
parlare la metà la maggior parte delle
volte che a noi capita di parlare lo
facciamo solo per rispondere non
ascoltiamo mai veramente ascoltiamo solo
la parte che ci interessa e scartiamo
tutto il resto siamo troppo impegnati a
fare altro a pensare ad altro tipo
[Applauso]
jd di scrubs siamo troppo impegnati ad
aver ragione che non riusciamo ad
ascoltare veramente come se la ragione
avesse veramente importanza in un
processo creativo
stai tranquillo non ne ha non esiste la
tua vanità tutti di metri al di sopra
dell'equazione perché quello che voglio
ottenere
che cosa più di te l'improvvisazione
insegna questo ti sei ad ascoltare che
insegna entrare in comunicazione con gli
altri ascoltare è la volontà di cambiare
in più
l'improvvisazione ti dice impara da
quelli bravi guarda in teatro e anche un
po consentito rubacchiare io vedo
qualcosa che mi piace qualcosa che
qualcuno ha fatto meglio di me e poi lo
prendo magari non lo rifaccio uguale
uguale uguale
l'idea si evolve cambia e magari la mia
e 2 finale è completamente diversa da
quella iniziale questo è
l'improvvisazione teatrale
un'altra cosa che gli dice
l'improvvisazione e questo lasciati
fallire
io sono tanti anni che faccio i corsi di
formazione per ragazzi e adulti e potrei
fare tranquillamente uno studio
sociologico su questa cosa
lasciarsi fallire chi è che non ha paura
di fallire nessuno di rete tutti quanti
hanno paura di fallire
però ho notato che ultimamente questa
forma aumentata
tutti hanno paura di fallire tutti hanno
paura di sbagliare tutti annunciano di
non farcela anch'io oggi avevo molta
paura a parlare qui in questa università
così importante vettore di sbagliare la
paura di non farcela però di essere
inadeguato
avevo paura di fallire magari anche
successo è successo imparerò da quello
che ho fatto nella prossima volta farò
meglio la paura è sicuramente una
condizione molto difficile con cui
convivere ma non è del tutto negativa la
paura acutizza i nostri sensi aumenta la
nostra concentrazione aumenta la nostra
attenzione dunque paradossalmente la
può essere una leva su cui fare forza
per spingerci più in alto
a me personalmente la povera la strizza
sempre aiutato molto prima di un evento
molto importante dobbiamo essere capaci
di ascoltarci dobbiamo riconoscere le
nostre emozioni e dobbiamo gestire la
famosa intelligenza emotiva
l'improvvisazione ti dice questo
ti ricordo che tutto e me non è
controllabile
io sono le regole del gioco e vado
avanti
sbaglio rifaccio cado mi rialzo le
improvvisazioni ti dice che il
fallimento può avere risvolti
estremamente positivi samuel beckett
diceva fallire ancora fallire meglio
tutti quanti sono convinti che è
successo sia ottenere tutto subito
la televisione internet youtuber i
blogger un gruppo di ragazzini
quindicenni che diventa milionario e
inventando una app
rose briciola re sul divano mentre mangi
biscotti tutto subito
adesso non ho tempo da perdere ce la
deve fare ce lo deve farcela calma easy
solo attraverso il fallimento
posso crescere io fallisco ma non sono
un fallito il fallimento non è l'opposto
del successo è un suo requisito concludo
questo mio intervento in questo viaggio
con fatto all'interno
dell'improvvisazione teatrale con una
frase con una citazione fossero fatte
tante oggi ma la volevo inserire perché
per me è illuminante e luisa resta che è
una famosa scrittrice cantante ci dice
quando mi dò le opportunità e il
permesso di fallire mib nello stesso
tempo il permesso di eccellere
grazie
[Applauso]